EFFORT TONIGHT AGAINST THE
TWO-TIME
HE'S BUZZING, AND NOW A PASS TO
THE POINT. CIRELLI.
CONNOR McDAVID ON THE MOVE!
McDAVID SCORES!PEED.
THAT'S THE ATTACKING NATURE OF
HIM.
THANDED OPPORTUNITY.
STOPPED BY KN WITH THE MAN
ADVANTAGE.
SPOKE CANDIDLY ABOUT THAT TO THE
MEDIA A FEW GAMESES
THE HAND AREA.
STICK VERY SIMILAR TO THEINEUP
ON THE FOURTH LINE, 24 YEAR OLD
FROM CALEDON,, ICING CALL
AGAINST THE McDAVID.
BUT HIS PASS, YAMAMOTO AND KANE
>> TERRIFIC LITTLE GIFT TO
McDAVID O O McDAVID.
SH CHAOS RIGHT HERE.
DOWN LOW RIGHT BACK.
HERE.
THE LATE W BACK TO TAMPAASS.
BIT OF A NO LOOKER AND THE
OILERS TAKE ADVANTAGE.
ANE CAME N
AFTERWARDS AND TRIED TO JUST JAM
IT
13th TIME THIS SEASON THAT
AS HE STEERED THAT ONE ASIDE. O.
DECIDED TO GO HOME.
AND THAT WAS A BIG PART OF H PL.
THAT STARTED THIS ALL IN MOTION.
MAROON, WE WERE TALKING
KUCHEROV OVER TO PARRY.
STAMKOS GIVES IT MIDDLE OFF AN
OILERS' STICK.
MAROON TO KILLORN.VE ON AND HE .
BOUNCING PUCK.
EVANDER KANE ALL THE WAY DOWN
THE SKATE OF
NURSE ON THAT HARD PASS ACROSS.
LOOKS LIKE IT'S GOING TO POINT.
IT GOES OFF THE SKATE